the u.s has recorded more than one
million new covet 19 infections on
monday that's a world record for
confirmed daily cases though it's partly
because of a reporting backlog after the
new year's holiday
confirmed infections have doubled in the
past week as omicron spreads across the
country but hospitalization and death
rates have been lower than in previous
waves the u.s center for disease control
has recommended shortening the weight
for booster jobs to five months but more
than a quarter of the population is
still completely unvaccinated
just moments ago u.s president joe biden
addressed the nation urging citizens to
get vaccinated
unvaccinated are taking up hospital beds
and crowding emergency rooms and
intensive care units that's just placing
other people who need access to those
hospitals
so please please please
get vaccinated now
so there's no excuse
no excuse for anyone being unvaccinated
this continues to be a pandemic of the
unvaccinated
so we've got to make more progress
and for patients who still haven't
gotten your kids vaccinated please get
them vaccinated
look out for their interest here it's
the best way to protect them
folks
i know we're all tired and frustrated
about the pandemic
these coming weeks are going to be
challenging
please wear your mask in public to
protect yourself and others
we're going to get through this
and to talk about the surge in
infections in the united states i'm now
joined by william shaffner he's
professor of preventive medicine at the
department of health policy at
vanderbilt university medical center in
nashville professor are you dismayed by
the low level of a vaccination now that
omicron is spreading
oh nick i am absolutely dismayed by the
low level of vaccination you know we
have been promoting vaccination for
months now but there is a contingent of
adults that are still hesitant skeptic
and i will say downright stubborn about
not receiving the vaccine and these are
frequently also people who are not
bringing their children forward to be
vaccinated and
in addition to that we of course have
people who have had two doses of the
mrna vaccine that still need their
booster for optimal protection so we
have an enormous amount of vaccination
work to do here in the united states
and do you think that perhaps some of
the
harsher measures or more rigorous
measures that europe is applying looking
at austria for instance where there's a
vaccine mandate
are needed or even possible in the
united states
ah the question is possible right you
can have a public policy but it has to
be generally accepted
there are two kind of populations in the
united states i'm part of the one group
that would like to have more obligations
and requirements for vaccination and
then of course there's a large number of
people who would push back against that
very very strongly
and i think we haven't come to a
consensus and it differs in different
states across the country i'm in
tennessee where we have a large
proportion of the unvaccinated still
and if if we could professor just talk a
little bit about the facts on the ground
the omicron variant that is spreading
faster than the delta but appears to be
at early reports less severe does this
mean that coronavirus is going to become
endemic something that we just have to
get used to living with permanently like
the flu for example
oh well the short answer to your
question is yes
coronaviruses covet is not going to
disappear
and we will have to cope with it as we
do with influenza on an ongoing basis uh
it is true omicron spreads widely
it can even infect
people who are vaccinated and boosted
but the important thing to focus on is
those people get mild disease
yes you could even have to go to bed for
a day or two but you don't require
hospitalization
hospitalization almost completely
still is
comes from people who are unvaccinated
at all and that's where the burden of
unvaccinated people are
and and hospitalizations and that's
what's straining our health care system
okay professor william schaffner talking
to us from nashville tennessee thanks
for your time
thank you
harry hyman is a public health professor
at georgia state university uh welcome
to the show professor at this current
wave of coronavirus infections hit first
in places like new york
how is it that hospitalization and
deaths have surged there even though the
vaccinations are relatively high there
well i think i think when you get
the kinds of very very high case counts
that you're getting
it's going to spread to people who are
susceptible
to more severe illness and even in a
state like new york where you have
about 71 percent of the population that
has finished their primary vaccination
it still means you've got 30 percent of
the population that's unvaccinated now
many of those are children uh and and
younger people but but it still means
that you have a significant portion of
the population that is very susceptible
to this virus
and and what role does the new
characteristics of the omicron variant
have in this spread in places like that
well i think we know from not just the
us but but south africa and the uk that
this is a very very uh fast spreading
highly contagious virus um and
um it's not only contagious to people
who are unvaccinated it's also
contagious to those who've been
vaccinated the good news is vaccines are
still highly protected so if you are
fully vaccinated and especially if
you're boosted
the likelihood of having a serious
illness is very low but that doesn't
mean that you can't catch the infection
uh and spread it to someone who maybe
has other underlying diseases uh or or
susceptibility to more severe infection
i'd like to ask just a question if
professor if if i may about one part of
the united states because it's so hard
to navigate the numbers sometimes
half of the tests in atlanta
uh are coming back positive and it's one
in three in the entire state of georgia
is that as bad as it sounds
uh yeah
it's as bad as it sounds
we're seeing a tremendous surge not just
in the metro area in atlanta but it's
now spreading to the more rural parts of
the state
and in georgia in contrast to new york
we have about 51 percent of the
population that's fully vaccinated so a
much lower percentage
and we also have much less in the way of
of policies
and and systems in place uh at the
community level to protect people
and and what's being done to to combat
the surge i guess it really depends on
the state and and the role of the
federal government at certain levels
well i think i think as with everything
it's it's it's federal state and and
local partnership and needless to say
that the federal government has been
working hard to expand access to
vaccinations something we've seen over
the past year we're still struggling
to make testing available uh to everyone
in every place and that's particularly
challenging now so even the numbers that
you quoted earlier about the number of
positive tests those are probably a
gross underestimate if you think about
the people who are doing home testing
and tests that aren't captured
by by the current data collection
systems
and there are rising rates of
hospitalization as we're just saying in
georgia and louisiana and mississippi
and florida um
what makes those states so vulnerable
that they can't cope beyond the fact
that there's a low vaccine uptake is is
there a political element as well
uh
you've been around long enough to know
there's a political element in
everything um
so yeah certainly uh we have a much
higher number of susceptible people
purely
from the fact that they're not
vaccinated but but in addition
there are basic
evidence-based public health measures
that we know work
like mass mandates and indoor settings
like vaccine mandates
both in public settings uh public
institutions and private businesses
and not only is there a lack of
state leadership
in supporting those kinds of policies
there's actually active obstruction
in states like georgia and florida i
mean just as an example
in georgia the the university system of
georgia which has over 300 000 students
universities are not allowed based on
what's called the board of regents that
dictates policies to mandate either mass
for indoor classes or vaccines and then
look at a state like florida where the
where the governor is actively
prohibiting k-12 schools from having
mass mandates i mean i mean those are
our policy approaches that are contrary
to uh not only what the what the what
the cdc uh recommends but just basic
common sense public health measures
about what we know will make a
difference
yeah well without passing judgment it
doesn't sound like anything we have in
europe professor harry hyman at the
georgia state university thanks so much
thank you very much
you